from beloved game show hosts to rock and
roll royalty to children's TV Legends
some true Giants have passed away in
2023 here's a look at who we've lost
fider on the roof wasn't the likeliest
candidate to be a Smash Hit musical
based on schm Mam's beloved tale of
Jewish life and the pale of settlement
the musical tells a story of a Milkman
named tavier who struggles to maintain
his Traditions accept his daughter's
potential husbands and to navigate a
hostile World Israeli actor Heim topul
or just topel as he was usually built
was a big part of the musical's success
and would forever be linked to the role
of tevia too portrayed tavier in
thousands of stage performances of
Fiddler on the Roof playing the part in
the original 1967 West End production
revivals in 1983 and 1994 and a Broadway
Revival in 1990 most prominently he
starred in the hit 1971 film adaptation
which landed him an Academy Award
nomination for best actor Topol also
portrayed Dr D Han zarov in the 1980
movie version of Flash Gordon and
Smuggler Columbo in the James Bond movie
for your eyes only topul who had been
diagnosed of Alzheimer's disease died in
Tel Aviv Israel on March 8th 2023 he was
87 there were three unique and distinct
phases in the life and career of Robert
Blake who started appearing in films in
the late 1930s at the age of 6 between
1939 and 1944 Bobby Blake portrayed
Mickey in more than three dozen hour
gang or Little Rascals theatrical shorts
that gave way to numerous appearances as
Little Beaver in Red Rider movie serials
and appearances on TV Western in the
1950s and 60s after playing convicted
killer Perry Smith in 1967's In Cold
Blood Blake star his detective Tony
Beretta on the TV crime drama Beretta
from 1975 to 1978 which won him an Emmy
Award in the ' 80s and '90s Blake
assumed a lot of tough guy roles
retiring after a memorably creepy
appearance appear in David Lynch's Lost
Highway in 1997 Blake would make
headlines when he was arrested and tried
for the 2001 murder of his wife Bonnie
Lee bakeley the salacious trial ended in
an acquittal but Blake was held liable
in a civil wrongful death suit and had
to pay his deceased wife's family $30
million the Associated Press reported
that Blake died at his Los Angeles home
from heart disease on March 9th 2023 he
was 89 Lance Ric brought an irresistible
energy to a series of high profile and
cult projects over the years his
intensity and deep character work often
made them Unforgettable reic broke out
on the HBO prison drama Oz where he
played undercover narcotics officer
Johnny basil he then starred in The Wire
as police Lieutenant Cedric Daniels reck
once again played a complex authority
figure federal agent Philip BRS head of
the titular paranormal office on Fringe
many more TV rols followed for redic
including deputy chief Irving on bsh
Albert Wesker on Netflix's Resident Evil
series series and deeply evil boss
Christian devil on comedy Central's
corporate film fans know him best as
Chiron a concierge turned sidekick of
the John Wick
movies Chiron would you help set the
mood for our new
guests of course
[Music]
sir Gamers remember him for years to
come as Commander Zavala of the Destiny
video game series reic was discovered
dead of natural causes in his home
outside Los Angeles on the morning of
March 17th 201 23 he was 60 years old
Michael Lerner was a character actor but
he retreated into the scenery a dominant
and commanding force in most every role
he took learner was a quintessential
supporting actor who specialized in
portraying adversarial authority figures
and bullying blowhards after starting
out in San Francisco theater in the
1960s learner took on many dues playing
roles on 70s and ' 80s TV shows
including Hill Street Blues and the
Rockford files and in movies such as
eight men outs and Harem Knights
probably his best known role was as the
tyrannical movie studio boss Jack lipnik
in Barton thinkink that part in the 1992
Cen Brothers cult classic earned Lerner
an Academy Award nomination Lerner
worked often through the '90s
co-starring in Newsies blank check and
in 1998 Godzilla as the ineffectual
mayor of a besieged New York City later
gigs included that of a nasty children's
book publisher in elf and an anti-mutant
senator in X-Men Days of Future Past Sam
learner Michael larner's nephew broke
the news of his uncle's death on
Instagram on April 9th 2023 Michael
Lerner was 81 a national treasur in his
home of Australia Barry Humphries worked
as a comedian actor and drag performer
for decades he's best known as his drag
alter iGo Dame Edna everage a saucy
purple-headed older woman from the Upper
Crust who says whatever is on her mind
often speaking truth to power I counsel
and I heal you counsel and you heal I do
a little bit of healing in addition to
portraying Dame Edna's odious rival sir
Les Patterson Humphrey appeared as a
signature character in hundreds of talk
shows TV series and movies for years
Dame edner was a virtual regular on The
Tonight Show and hosted the marck talk
show Dame Edna's Hollywood on NBC in the
early 1990s Pixar fans will recognize
humre as a voice of Bruce the shark from
Finding Nemo he also voiced a great
Goblin in Peter Jackson's The Hobbit and
Unexpected Journey humph was so beloved
in Australia that his death was reported
to the public by the country's prime
minister Anthony albanes humre was 89
years old born in Harlem to a family
from the Caribbean Harry bellafante was
America's biggest black multi henet
Superstar during the mid 20th century in
the 1950s balante was the biggest pop
singer in the United States he sang
traditional and new songs in Caribbean
based Styles including his signature
tune Deo the Banana Boat Song and topped
the billboard album chart for 31 weeks
in the 1950s singer starred in the
musical movie kmen Jones the romance
Island and the Sun and the
post-apocalyptic the World the Flesh and
the devil after a long break to focus on
the Civil Rights Movement where he was a
prominent and outspoken advocate for
African-American equality and systemic
change working closely with Dr Martin
Luther King Jr bellante returned to
acting in the 1970s appearing in buck
and the preacher and Uptown Saturday
Night its final onscreen work was a
supporting role in 2018s Black Clansman
balante died of congestive heart failure
at his home in New York on April 25th
2023 and 96 years old the NFL became
nationally popular in the 1960s thanks
to television and explosive stars like
running back Jim Brown in his 9-year
career Brown was named to nine Pro bow
squads never missed the game and set the
records for yards and touchdowns after
leading the Cleveland Browns to its last
League Championship and being named the
NFL's Most Valuable Player in 1965 Brown
decided to apply his talents to acting
his first major film role was in the
classic war movie The Dirty Dozen he'd
go on to star in many more action films
in the 8S and '90s brown did some
episodic TV work appearing on chips
Night Rider and the A Team before poking
fun at his career and tough guy persona
in comedies like I'm going to get you
sucker and Mars Attacks Brown's personal
life was full of controversy he faced
multiple assault charges in 1968 for
example he allegedly threw a female
partner from a balcony and in 1999 he
was arrested after taking a shovel to
his wife's car and allegedly threatening
to kill her in both cases the women
withdrew their allegations a family
representative told the Associated Press
that Brown died at his home in Los
Angeles on May 18th
2023 age 87 after cutting his teeth with
small roles on British television series
in the 1990s Northern Irish actor Ray
Stevenson became a prolific go-to guide
for producers all over the world looking
to bring gravity and intensity to their
films and TV series his first prominent
gig came in the 2004 film King Arthur as
a self-sacrificing knight Dagon he
followed that with a run on HBO's Rome a
soldier Titus pul Stevenson then snagged
a starring role in Punisher war zone
portraying the title vigilante in
addition to supporting roles in the
Three Musketeers GI Joe retaliation and
the Book of Eli Stevenson also appeared
in the first three MCU Thor films as
Thor's pal volag as well as in Divergent
as abnegation leader Marcus Eon
Stevenson was heavily involved in the
Star Wars Universe voicing gar Saxon in
multiple projects and playing balen
scull in the Disney plus Ahsoka series
getting to to wield the lightsaber is
just the best feeling in the world he
also played the villainous governor
Scott buckston in the Indian hit R and
worked alongside martial arts star Scott
Atkins in the accident Man series his
publicist told variety that the actor
died in Italy on May 2st 2023 Stevenson
was 58 years old born Anime Bullock Tina
Turner would become an iconic musician
and earned the nickname the Queen of
rock and roll combining a raspy voice
passionate performance style and
frenetic dance moves Turner propelled
her duo with her then husband Ike Turner
into massive success in the 1960s and
1970s in the 1980s Turner returned to
prominence as a solo act and struck it
even bigger ultimately selling 180
million albums and winning 12 Grammy
Awards Turner was so famous recognizable
and charismatic the Hollywood eventually
beckoned Turner took on just four film
roles but all memorable she appeared as
the Acid Queen in Tommy made a cameo in
Sergeant Pepper's Lonely Hearts Club
Band Played the villainous ATI entity in
madmax Beyond Thunderdome and appeared
as a mayor in Last Action Hero Turner's
family released a statement to Rolling
Stone on May 24th 2023 announcing the
Rockstar's death at her home in
Switzerland Turner passing came after a
lengthy sickness she was 83 years old
starting out in the claimed films in the
1970s Treat Williams spent the 1980s and
1990s popping up in everything from
Prestige movies to crowd Pleasers to
made for television Fair Williams broke
out with a major role as hippie leader
Burger in the 1979 film adaptation of
the musical hair then appeared in Steven
Spielberg's 1941 and the harrowing
police drama Prince of the City which
earned him a Golden Globe nomination
he'd never be off to dream for long
co-starring in crime sagas such as Once
Upon a Time in America and things to do
in Denver when you're dead over the
course of his prolific career Williams
racked up more than 100 acting credits
and these days he's remembered by many
for numerous Christmas projects for
Hallmark and Netflix as well as playing
dads in Chicago Fire white collar and
Chesapeake shorts what many consider
William's signature role came in the
wb's family drama Everwood where he
started as kindly neurosurgeon and
compassionate single father Dr Andy
Brown William will s agent Barry
mcferson told The Hollywood Reporter
that the actor was riding his motorcycle
near his home outside dorsed for mon on
June 12th 2023 when he was struck by a
car after an airlift to Albany Medical
Center in New York for treatment of
severe injuries Williams was pronounced
dead at age 71 across a variety of film
genres and highend Theatrical
Productions glender Jackson was among
the most acclaimed actors of both her
generation and the mid 20th century a
member of the royal Shakespeare company
in the 1960s Jackson portrayed ofilia in
a notable Hamlet staging and originated
the role of Charlotte cord in the London
production of the controversial play
morat sad receiving a Tony nomination
when the work moved to Broadway Jackson
then moved into film with a lead role in
1970s women in love winning her first of
two Academy Awards for Best Actress she
won the other for the 1973 romantic
comedy A Touch of Class more Oscar Noms
arrived for Sunday Bloody Sunday and
header with more tony notices for
strange interlude and MCB Beth in 1992
Jackson sidelined her extremely
distinguished acting career for politics
running for and winning a seat in the
UK's House of Commons she go on to serve
as Junior transport Minister for Prime
Minister Tony Blair after retiring from
public service in 2015 Jackson returned
to acting portraying the title role in a
London based King Leah and winning a
Tony Award for three tall women
according to a statement issued by
Jackson's agent and friend lonol Lana
the actor died at her home in London
following a short period of illness
Jackson was 87 Julian sanss brought
intensity and gravitas to more than 150
film and television roles dating back
four decades in the 1980s and 1990s Sans
made a big impression with major roles
in the claimed films such as the Killing
Fields A Room With a View and impromptu
while also starring in scary Fair like
Gothic the Warlock movies and a
Arachnophobia you've been
busy incredible Sans also seged into TV
voice acting on Biker Mice from Ms and
Jackie Chan Adventures before starring
as ulish on Banshee and recurring on
Smallville as Superman's father jel in
early 2023 just after his 65th birthday
Sans went hiking near Mount baly in
California San Gabriel mountains and
didn't return prompting his family to
file a missing person's report
snowstorms interrupted rescue efforts
until spring on June 24th the San
Bernardino sheriff's office reported
that hikers had found human remains in
the area where Sands disappeared 3 days
later they were conclusively identified
as those of the actor Alan Arin
consistently appeared in films and TV
series since the 1960s specializing in
playing gregarious over-the-top and
self-deprecating figures an early figure
in the Improv movement that would shape
20th century comedy arkim was among the
first members of Chicago's Second City
Theater part of the program's Broadway
debut in 1961 Arin would win a Tony
Award in 1963 for enter laughing Just 4
years years after that he'd receive an
Emmy nomination for the Love Song of
Barney kinsky and an Oscar nomination
for the Cold War fast the Russians are
coming the Russians are coming the
Oscars would recognize Arin a few more
times with nods for 1968's the heart is
a Lonely Hunter and 2012's Aro he
finally got a win for 2006's Little Miss
Sunshine for the role of unhinged
Grandpa Edwin in between those career
bookends Arin St in numerous and various
well-received films including Wait Until
Dark Catch 22 last of the red hot lovers
the in-laws Edward Scissor Hands and
Gross Point Blank according to a
statement from our kin Sons the actor
died on June 29th at his ksbar
California home at 89 years old a
definitive icon of the mid 20th century
sexy French aesthetic that spread
through pop culture Jame Burkin was a
Singer model fashion figure and actor
from the 1960s onward born in London and
coming of age during the city swinging
60s Burkin relocated to Paris where she
found success as an actor and singer but
particularly with her partner French
Superstar Serge gainsburg whom she
connected with on the set of the movie
slogan the envelope pushing abundantly
sensual 1969 single jimu was banned in
many places but it launched a long
musical career and made Burkin hugely
famous Burkin appeared in numerous edgy
1960s and 1970s movies including blowup
wonder wall Laine and Death on the Nile
in 1984 the same year AES introduced the
highly coveted Burk bag which was
inspired by the Entertainer Burkin
sardin laat which earned her the first
of three Cesar Award nominations
followed by La F Mari and label noaz
Burkin performed well into her 70s a
stroke and broken shoulder led to
multiple canceled engagements in 2023 on
July 16th 2023 she died at her Paris
home at age 76 a major character actor
lelia goni had a knack for collaborating
with major URS trained as a dancer with
the ler to Horton dancers goni switched
to acting in her late teens and studied
with John cassavetes in 1958 Shadows
aari improvised film about then
controversial issues like interracial
relationships he cast galoni as a black
woman believed by others to be white
shadows gued galoni a baa award
nomination for most promising newcomer
soon after she appeared in The Italian
Job the day of the Locust and Philip
kofman's 1978 remake of Invasion of the
Body snatches gon earned a second bath
theut for a supporting role in Martin's
GIS Alice doesn't live here anymore goni
died on July 22nd 2022 at the actors
fund home in Englewood New Jersey she
was 86 in the 1970s paor Rubin helped
turn the Los Angeles comedy Collective
the Groundlings into a workshop for top
level sketch comedians he part laid that
into 1980s the PeeWee Herman show a full
length production that send up and
Darkly skewed oldfashioned Kitty TV
shows and he played the title role a
high voiced overly made up aescent
Manchild if I could fly I'd be the
luckiest boy in the world the show was
such a hits that HBO taped it and
brought Peewee Mania National leading to
the 1985 feature film peewee's big
adventure the 1988 sequel big top peewee
and the live action Emmy winning
Saturday morning classic peewee's
playhouse in the 1980s Ruben's almost
always appeared in public fully in
character and costume as peee even
hosting Saturday Night Live in that guys
after playhouse ended in 19 90 Ruben's
retired Peewee and delved into primarily
comedy character work popping up briefly
with memorable roles in film and TV
Ruben portrayed the Penguin's father in
Batman Returns a vampire Lackey in Buffy
the Vampire Slayer a monstrous blue
blood on 30 Rock and spleen in Mystery
Men in 2016 he revived Peewee for the
Netflix original peewee's big holiday on
July 31st 2023 a message on Reuben's
Instagram account revealed that the
actor and comedian died the previous
even evening with a post that read in
part Paul bravely and privately fought
cancer for years with his trademark
tenacity and wit ruin was 70 while Angus
Cloud attended the same Oakland
performing art school with his eventual
Euphoria co-stars and DEA he was working
in a New York restaurant when presented
with the opportunity to audition for the
popular and influential HBO team drama
series Cloud quickly became a pivotal
member of the Euphoria ensemble cast in
its first two seasons as emotionally
complex drug dealer fesco A supplier to
Ru and love interest for Lexi
additionally Cloud made appearances in
the films North Hollywood and the line
popped up in several music videos and
was set to co-star in an anthology film
and a horror movie from the makers of
Scream 6 on the morning of July 31st
2023 the Oakland fire department
answered an emergency call whereupon
they discovered Cloud's body Cloud's
family released a statement to noting
the actor's history with mental health
issues and how his passing followed the
death of his father by Mia days it was
later confirmed that the actor had died
due to an accidental overdose Cloud was
25 years old a highly recognizable and
prolific actor Mark margolus brought a
palpable and captivating intensity to
his roles which often called for
intimidating dangerous underworld
figures margolus broke out as Alberto
the shadow in the 1983 crime classic
Scarface for 5 years in the late 1990s
and early 2000s margolus portrayed
organized crime Lord Antonio Nappa on
HBO's Bleak prison drama Oz around on
the same time margolus began a long
collaboration with filmmaker Darren
aronowski playing a math genius in pi
and rols in several of the directors
other films but margolus is best known
for his portrayal of high-ranking drug
trafficking figure Hector salamona on
Breaking Bad and its prequel better
Coral the character couldn't speak
requiring margolus to do all his acting
with his face and a bell in 2012 the
performance earned margolus an Emmy
Award nomination for outstanding guest
actor in a drama series following a
brief period of sickness margolus died
at New York City's Mount Si Hospital the
actor was 83 Johnny Hardwick R appeared
in front of the camera so he's likely
not as recognizable for his face as he
is for his voice he portrayed an
effectual oblivious chainsm smoking
exterminator and conspiracy theorist
Dale Gribble in the Animated Series King
of the Hill for 13 years how is cutting
down on pollution a government plot Dale
open up your eyes man they're trying to
control global warming when the show is
in pre-production King of the Hill
co-creator Greg Daniels attended a
comedy Showcase in Los Angeles after
hearing the Austin based Hardwick tell
some funny stories about his father he
hired the comic to be part of the
writing staff for the Texas spoofing
cartoon then hard work auditioned to
play Dale and got the part his first
credited role on a filmography that
includes numerous independent projects
He also remained on the writing staff of
King of the Hill part of the team that
won a 1999 Emmy Award for outstanding
animated program summons to Hardwick
saus in home on August 8th to perform a
well welfare check police found the body
of the actor and writer Hardwick was 64
alen Sim was a consistent presence on
network television for decades in 1984
she started a 400 plus episode run on
Days of Our Lives as kopy Jones Bradford
a role that would Garner her four Soap
Opera Digest Awards and two Daytime Emmy
Award nominations sorin parlayed that
into a supporting role on the 1987
sitcom duet one of the first ever [__]
shows and its spin-off open house the
actor also Al hosted the America's
Funniest Home Video spin-off America's
funniest people in addition to winning a
Peabody Award for her work producing the
2010 documentary boo sain's grandest
achievement is originating and defining
the role of Harley Quinn in numerous
animated DC Comics projects beginning
with Batman the Animated Series in 1992
sain voiced the character in 12 projects
total across video TV and the internet
sain's death was announced on August
26th 2023 she was 66 7 while not
primarily an actor Bob Barker was an
Entertainer television star and
household name while hosting the Bob
Barker show in 1950 Los Angeles he was
plucked to host a television version of
the popular radio game show Truth or
Consequences a gig Barker held for 18
years his follow-up project lasted even
longer and made him a legend in 1972
Barka hosted the first of more than
6,500 episodes of The Price is Right he
retired in 2007 collecting 19 me Awards
along the way thanks to the Price's
right the many televised pageants he
hosted and his animal rights activism
Barker became famous for being Bob
Barker help control the pet population
have your pets f n he even played
fictionalized heightened versions of
himself from time to time Barker
contributed cameos to Futurama Yes dear
How I Met Your Mother The Nanny and most
famously Happy Gilmore in the 1996
comedy he memorably and thoroughly
pummels Adam Sandler's character on a
golf course Barker's publicist announced
on August 26th 2023 that the game show
host had died Barker was
99 initially a stage actor in his native
South Korea bian heong moved into voice
acting on television in the 1960s he'
eventually become a prolific often cast
award-winning character actor on popular
and notable Korean TV shows including
the First Republic and White Tower
however Bean would find International
recognition when he began a series of
collaborations with acclaimed filmmaker
bong junho he portrayed Sergeant Ki bong
in 2003's memories of murder and Park
Family patriarch he bong in 2006's box
office smash the host BM was most likely
best known for his role as the lead
character's grandfather in bongan film
festival and Netflix hit Fantasy oga on
September 18th 2023 bian died After
experiencing medical issues related to a
recurrence of diagnosed and treated
pancreatic cancer Bean was 81 years old
after landing breakthrough roles in 60s
Classics a great escape and the greatest
story ever told David McCullum enjoyed a
long and illustrious career book ended
by playing major characters on two erid
defining TV series about intelligence
agents in the James Bond influence 1964
spy series A Man from Uncle mcallum
played Elite secret agent Ilia kurakin
who along with Robert vaugh solo waged a
weekly War around the world against a
nefarious thrush mullum would reprise
the RO in multiple TV projects along
with the big screen Uncle off shoots one
spy too many one of our spies is missing
and the karate Killers then in 2003
mallum co-starred on NCIS as Dr Donald
ducky malard a veteran criminal profiler
and provider of lowkey comic relief
mallum died of natural causes in New
York City on September 25th
2023 he was 90 years old one of the most
acclaimed and prolific actors of his
generation Michael Gambon began his long
cinematic career in 1965 having a small
role in Lawrence Olivier's adaptation of
Shakespeare's aello Gambon broke out
internationally in the'80s with the 1985
romance turtle diary and the 1986 TV
series The Singing detective that show
when gamban his first baa TV award a
prize he also took home for wives and
daughters longitude and perfect
strangers in the US Gambon was nominated
for Emmys for his work in path to war
and 2009's Emma also a star of the
British stage and winner of three
Olivier Awards gamban is probably best
known for his post 2000 work such as
voicing uncle pastuzo in the Paddington
films ands the villainous bean and
Fantastic Mr Fox after the late Richard
Harris died in 2002 gambal was picked to
play the part of Hogwarts head Master
Albert Dumbledore in the Harry Potter
series guiding and assisting the boy who
lived over the course of six films on
September 28 2023 gamon's family
announced that the actor had died after
Contracting pneumonia Gambon was 82
years
old